este edificio que está a mis espaldas
donde estas excavadoras mueven esta hora
los escombros era hasta esta mañana el
hospital municipal de nipro donde
también
atendían personas que venían a
tratamientos psiquiátrico era también
considerado el hospital psiquiátrico de
la ciudad según nos cuentan los vecinos
que aseguran que a las 10:30 de la
mañana sintieron Cómo eran atacados con
un misil muchos de ellos que estaban en
los apartamentos aledaños que también
están dañados alcanzaron a tirarse el
piso y el impacto fue tan grande que el
resultado es lo que estamos viendo en
este momento el edificio está totalmente
destruido todavía sigue quemándose
todavía y fuego y a esta hora los
bomberos como vemos Todavía siguen
intentando Apagar este fuego a pesar de
que llueve en estos momentos ya llovido
durante la tarde en las horas en deni
pro también cuentan los vecinos y las
autoridades que al menos dos personas
han fallecido 30 han quedado herido así
hay tres personas desaparecidas pero no
saben a estas horas Si todavía están en
este edificio vemos Que ya remueven con
mucha más crudeza los escombros que
están allí y también al preguntarles a
los habitantes Y esta es una zona
militar Ellos dicen que aquí no hay
ninguna presencia militar que en el
pasado llegaron a atacar una fábrica que
trabaja con el con la empresa
ferroviaria de Ucrania pero hace ya
meses que este sector no lo era no
estaba siendo atacado sin embargo si
dicen que fue una de las noches más
duras en Nitro en los últimos meses
Rusia lanzó 17 misiles contra Ucrania
10 de ellos fueron interceptados la
mayoría de ellos En kiev y siete de
ellos impactaron tanto en harkies como
aquí en Nitro durante la noche pero como
decía fue ya las diez y media de la
mañana que este misil cae en este lugar
donde hubo los mayores daños y también
las mayores consecuencias humanas el
presidente abogado se refirió a esto
como un crimen de lesa humanidad